[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
a piece of organic sensor coming up on
tonight's program the king of the ring
is back for round two world heavyweight
champion tyson fury is uncensored and so
is his wife paris
environmentalist stanley johnson is here
to talk trophy hunting and big beasts of
the serengeti and of british politics
and our sport sold out to saudi arabia
i'll be talking sports watching to
football legend harry redknapp
at seven weeks today fresh from his
knockout win over dillian white in front
of 94 000 spectators at wembley the
heavyweight champion of the world tyson
fury looked me and looked you in the eye
and announced to the world he was not
going to fight again
well let me tell you something pierce
morgan uncensored this is the truth the
gospel truth nothing but the truth i'm
done
you know every good dog has its day and
like the great roman leader said
there'll always be somebody else to
fight when is enough enough i'm happy
i'm healthy i've still got my brains i
can still talk i've got a beautiful wife
i've got six kids i've got obtained
belts i've got plenty of money success
fame glory
what what more am i doing it
well this morning in the sun newspaper
tyson gave a little hint
that it may not be
completely out of the question that he
might come out of a time for a reported
200 million pound fight to unify all the
titles so what's changed i'm glad to say
that tyson is joining me with the
beautiful wife paris that he talked
about in our last interview good evening
to both of you
good evening
there now tyson i've got one question to
ask you when you looked me in the eye
those weeks ago yeah you vowed you were
never ever going to fight again
did you mean it
yeah
yes
yeah so you're not gonna fight again
no i still mean it pierce
so when you're not gonna be fighting any
more professional fights i'm finished
what happens if the joshua yousick fight
in august in saudi arabia is a bit of a
thriller and joshua wins
and the jungle drums begin beating that
the whole of britain wants to see you
finally get in a ring with anthony
joshua and frank warren being the
brilliant promoter that he is
puts a check on the table in front of
you
for such a gargantuan summer money you
think you know what i've got one bit of
unfinished business and it's joshua
no you know i don't care who wins out
the fight i wish i'm both luck in the
world
um i'm done i told you i was done seven
weeks ago i meant it there's some talk
of me having some exhibition fights but
to be honest with you i can't see that
coming off either um because i've got no
real interest in fighting anymore um
it's not just the fight on the night
it's all stuff in the gym taking punches
to the head
it's just enough is enough for me um i
put a ridiculous number on today i said
i'll come back for half a billy half a
billion pounds that's 500 million so if
that's not ridiculous
ridiculous enough to believe i'm not
coming back for boxing i don't know what
it is but somebody i'm frank warren is a
good provider but somebody might get
somebody might get that number for you
they might get that number for you if
they do
if they do if they say look it's the
table it's half a billion would you take
it
yeah
listen i would definitely look at it if
there's half a billion on the table just
look at it
i'll have to look at that offer just
have a look so paris you're not going to
see it
for billy well let me come to your wife
who i suspect you know probably wears
the the rings in this in this marriage
paris
how would you feel because i know after
the wilder trilogy he vowed he wasn't
going to fight again and you well you
believed him and he did then fight again
well after the first fight
yeah do you think he means his first
fight wilder i begged him not to fight
again and then he obviously fought on
and he had the trilogy and then he's
fought again just the other day in
wembley and he says he's definitely
quitting and he's definitely finishing
on top but
there's just still a glint in his eyes
that i see
and i just i just don't know i'd like
him to retire everybody in his family
we're all happy with everything he's
done and he's just obviously he's done
amazing but
i just
don't know there's something in the back
of my mind that thinks tyson's still
itching for certain fights
we're here honestly this is why and he
tells me no
and i would love to believe it
but i'm just not quite there i think i'm
with the rest of the public thinking is
it true you see paris this is why i
wanted you in this interview because the
wives always know tyson if it was just
me and you i'd be taking all this at
face value but the woman you love
who you live with who knows you better
than any personal life
she sees that glint in your eye
and she thinks there's unfinished
business
okay i'll ask her a question while
you're on paris yeah do you want me to
fight again for any amount of money no
yes or no no 100 million or 200 million
change our lives not at all but when
have you done what i've asked you to do
he always does what he wants to do he
will only do what he wants to do whether
it pleases me him or everybody he's only
going to do what he wants to do and what
if i said i'm not going to fight i said
warren i've told bob arum i've told
everybody tyson theory and fighting
is finished
the money is not tempting to me to be
fair um
but there's something still calling you
out there because the other day you were
saying oh i want to do expeditions i
don't i might do this and i might do
that you train every day like a crazy
trojan yeah but i do train for mental
health and emotional fitness and
everything else but the fact of the
matter is
i might might do an exhibition
exhibitions are not real fights just
pretend play time showtime entertainment
but there's still something calling you
there and i just wonder you never know i
i hope you retired and i hope it stays
that way but it's one of them
we'll wait and see us
i'll have to wait do i have to stay out
the ring before i'm officially retired
then i don't know i think he was retired
for 10 minutes on box rep wasn't he
well i have been out the ring before for
three years three years and i came back
now tyson i'm never saying never but it
so i said we're just gonna we've got a
slight issue with your microphone so i'm
gonna talk to paris and we're gonna go
full screen with paris here while we fix
your mic and then we'll come back to
paris parish is actually doing a
brilliant job on my behalf getting the
truth out of you so we're going to come
just to paris for a moment apparently
yeah
and we're going to fix tyson's might
what we do okay so paris here's
what i want to talk to you about you
first met tyson when you when you were
what age
uh 15 15 years old 15 i was pierced
you've had a remarkably uh
long successful not always perfect
marriage
to somebody who is i think one of the
most unique people i've ever met in
sport
uh uniquely smart uniquely fascinating
uh you know had his troubles always talk
so openly about them what's it been like
to be with tyson all this time and how
have you seen him evolve
um tyson has always been up and down and
always been this crazy lovable person
that he is
and he's evolved in the fact that i
think he's matured which i do think all
men take a little bit longer to do and
he is now
happy and content in his life and i
think that's why he's retired i think
that's why in his heart and soul he's
happy with everything he's done and the
career went great everything that he
ever wanted to do and told me all them
years ago even as a young boy at 15 or
16 he told me i'm going to be
heavyweight champ of the world i didn't
really believe it i didn't didn't
believe that he couldn't do it i just
thought he'd probably get picked up in
other things um but tyson has done it
and i think he's happy and contented
which has made our life just brilliant
and everything's running really well
we've got six healthy children we're
happy and we're doing great so to tick
all the boxes he's done that
and he's contented with his career and
his life of what he's done but
as the wife i just
i just look and i just wonder are you
doing as much as everyone else and i
hope he is i hope that with like
boxing's dawn and he chooses another
path and finds something that he's
passionate about and carries on with it
but
will he stay out the ring i honestly and
we're sitting here together and whatever
whatever we say afterwards but i do
think there's a question mark there
i do too we're gonna take a short break
when we come back i'll be back to you
tyson with some more tough questions on
piers morgan uncensored
[Music]
do
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to peterborough uncensored
here's round two with tyson paris fury
so i know we've got you back on a on a
proper mic again which is good we can
hear you loud and clear so look your
wife's having none of this she sees the
glint she thinks there's unfinished
business
and i'm with paris on this
yeah are you with a lot of other people
as well it's me dad my lawyer my wife
well me and the lawyer have a bet don't
we yeah i i just think i'm the only
person who actually believes in what i'm
saying you know a lot of people say no
tyson fury doesn't know when he's
telling the truth himself
but you know
me word can be me bond and well it can
be tried and tested the future will will
tell if i'm telling the truth or not how
about this how about given if you do
fight again you're going to get a barrel
load of
cash
gazillions how about if you do fight
again you have to give me a million
pounds
how about that's a deal
really can i join in on that yeah you
can have a million pounds as well paris
so we have a deal do we you'll give me a
million quid if you fight if i'm getting
half a billion yeah exactly yeah i'll
give you a million quid i'll get paris
one two all right
half a billion from me fight it won't
matter will it all right so paris and i
will get a million pounds each if you
fight again
yeah 100
i love that deal because i got a feeling
we're going to cash in paris
what's a million pounds
me can you please surround me
tyson i have to now apologize for your
bad language you're a very naughty boy
oh
i thought this was uncensored pierce
morgan
still early it's not that unsensitive
um let me ask you uh tyson
about uh love
because you're a passionate man you're
an emotional man and you've got this
beautiful woman that has been with you
since you were both very young what has
been the secret of your
romance together
i think i'm very qualified to speak on
the matter of love because
i've been married 13 nearly 14 years
this year started as kids together from
15 16.
six kids and all that so yeah i think
love is a fantastic um
thing if you can ever find love in your
life whether it's you're loving someone
or you have a love for something
it's a fantastic fantastic thing and
someone who's never experienced love can
have the world but they'll have nothing
to love affair with like sports and me
yeah but tyson have you have you ever
been in love with anybody else or has
paris been the one always for you
paris has been my first love and only
love as in a person
but i have
i've had a
a really vicious love affair
keep going we're boxing
on and off my whole life
paris when you hear
paris when you hear this this man
mountain this this world heavyweight
champion this all-time great of the
sport when you hear him being so
romantic how does it make you feel
do you know what peace you've got to
take in fact that tyson's just my
husband it's not heavyweight champ it's
not nothing special like yes i can
credit him and say he's done really well
but at the end of the day me and him has
just been together for me and kids and
i don't look at him in that light so for
him to say that i think well yeah that's
good that's lovely of course her husband
should love his wife and vice versa you
should love the person you're with you
should love your partner no matter what
so
that's obviously a bit given isn't it
you can't really be with someone if you
don't want to be with them and you don't
love them and paris what are the best i
don't look at it later it's one of those
big fighters what are the best and worst
things about tyson from a wife's
perspective
be honest now because we're on the pace
morgan show we're here to tell the truth
the truth is uncensored the bestest
thing is house yeah is how
crazy and
spontaneous and
outgoing and
talkative and everything he has with him
that's the greatest side of him
and then that's also the worst side of
him because that has two sides of the
table you've got the great sides of like
right come on we're going somewhere
today and everything's happy but then
you've got the the other side that's
like hey wake up come on get up get
packed i want to leave i'm going to
china tonight so you've got the good and
the bad and
i i don't know i can't say the bad or
the good tyson's obviously had his ups
and downs and we've been through it all
together so
we're just through it through thick and
thin aren't we
you're a fantastic i think you're a
fantastic couple i do i i've and i know
it's not she's like my ride ride or die
she's my ride or die chick pearce
let me ask you when i do the bank
robbery she's driving the car
let me ask you tyson when i did
celebrity apprentices in america uh with
lennox lewis we were we were stuck
together for about six weeks and became
good friends and i got a lot of time for
lennox but he told me when he was the
heavyweight champion of the world when
he used to go out clubbing especially in
sort of new york and so on the biggest
guy in every place they went at some
stage of the night would come and try it
on want to have a fight
do you get that
yeah
do you know what great question
no i don't get it anywhere because i
don't walk around like i'm a heavyweight
champion of the world i've not got a
chip on my shoulder and my aura is come
here i want to give you a hug and sing
he was hung my auras not let me punch
you in the face i'm a tough guy
so never once in my whole life yeah i
can vouch for that i've never ever seen
it no one has ever approached me for a
fight or approached me in aggressive
manner no because i'm not that i've not
got that aura or edge on me where i need
to prove myself or whatever you're not
like aggressive macho man yeah no i'd
rather just sing and dance and have a
beer and whatever else well i'll tell
you why i was asking because um as you
may have seen the books of julius
francis who actually fought mike tyson
um he was now he's now doing security
and he got into this incident a couple
of days ago just show a little clip this
is a box park at wembley
[Applause]
now it's interesting he's they aren't
going to charge him with anything for
this even though he's not the guy out i
watched the whole video this guy was
abusing julius francis abusing everybody
else and eventually he looked like he
was threatening julius francis and
julius chin did what did you make of
that
yeah
you know
all of it i saw the video i've seen it
i've seen the knockout great right on by
the way um
but you know this is what happens when
you're cheeky rude getting in people's
faces punching them whatever what do you
expect
if you keep kicking a dog it's going to
bite you isn't it
and you know these guys are there doing
a job there wasn't all on the lash
together
this guy is probably pissed off or
whatever had a few drinks
get cheeky these guys are doing their
job he's attacking them whatever so he's
been chinned um
and it's a life lesson
never go out and be cheeky to big men
because you're probably going to get
chinned
i love the fact that uh tyson
well other fact you said he'd rather
sing because i recently interviewed as
you know don mclean
the great uh american singer-songwriter
who gave us american pie here's what don
mclean said about you
after you gave us that kind message
i was going to tell tyson i love to meet
him someday i love him he is what boxing
has needed
he is a lovable champion and he's a
great champion and i wanted to tell him
that um whenever i get in trouble now
i'm going to say that i have him as my
best friend and i'm going to warn
anybody who's trying to mess with me
that i have him on speed dial you know
what i mean
what do you think of that tyson
i said don's a great guy i only spoke to
him yesterday on instagram he said he's
over in the uk november december so i
said let's hang out and have a beer so
this is crazy i'm going to be having a
beer with don mclean i'm probably
singing uh a version of american pie
together again well yeah the american
pie song that was released recently
featuring myself and don yeah it's um
it's won a load of awards so yeah do you
feel like giving us a little burst now
title someone that can't really sing
what would you like to wear i'd like to
hear a bit of american pie please
so bye bye miss american pie drove my
chevy to the levee but the levee was dry
them good old boys were drinking whiskey
and right
singing
do you know what is crazy though like
everyone keeps telling tyson you're a
great singer a great singer now yeah
he's good he's okay but they're actually
offering him record songs now record
labels are coming to him and offering
him songs and albums
he can't sing what are you doing
who is listening to this song i i'm a
bit of a
bit of a negative one on that one she's
negative on that one paris on a more
positive note there are rumors swirling
that there may be another addition to
the fury household can you say anything
about that
ah i've heard about these rumors for
about
four two months now
and shall we just clarify yeah you can
it ain't true
i've heard this for months and i keep
leaving it and i keep thinking where are
they gonna wake up i have lost a good
bit of weight recently i'm feeling
pretty body proud and it's like everyone
keeps saying she's pregnant she's
pregnant no no no we've got six and
we're happy with that number right now
well you look fantastic and tyson as you
know you are batting away put it this
way pace yes we will have another child
before i fight again i'm really got six
that's a guaranteed fact well i've got
listen if you fight again i've got my
million quid coming my way uh but tyson
i think you would accept that you are
good me too
to use the the the vernacular phrase
tyson you are punching way above your
weight i think you'd agree right
thank you very much pierce he won't
agree because he's he's a he's a very
competitive guy that'll never happen
he'll never agree
i agree my wife is is she's fantastic
she's had six kids she's that's alive
she's probably had about ten that we've
lost a few as well along the way
she is a full-time mother housewife
everything she's the best-selling author
she's done so many things and she looks
fantastic so you know i've done all
right
i used to look good when i had hair and
all i bought now i'm like the beast from
the east
the big old ugly ball did it fella oh i
make it with it
in character in character
in my character i look like brad pitt
uh i've got to mention your talk i can
talk to you guys all night but sadly i
have to leave it there you've got a new
talk coming fury fest the official after
party tour it would include a meet and
greet with with you with a q a and more
the first day i think is this friday in
london tickets are on sale now give me a
quick uh sort of early preview of what
it's about tyson
it's you know it's about the the boxing
career it's the mental health um story
it's everything you know give people an
opportunity to come and sit down and
listen maybe they're suffering with
mental health for self maybe they're
having boxing funds or maybe they just
want a fantastic night so if you haven't
got tickets already get tickets there's
only 16 shows on the first leg um and
i'm selling out really quick so get
yours right now brilliant tyson paris
what a pleasure to talk to you both
really loved that you were both
gloriously uncensored please come back
again soon it's always great to have you
on the show
thanks very much for always having us on
you are the best and you're watching
piss morgan on sexy
i love it chad i love it
great to talk to you both all the time
bye guys
bye now bye-bye thank you
brilliant absolutely brilliant i love
thai stuff and i love paris fury what a
wonderful couple aren't they uh
brilliant
a sense of nexus golf stars spurn the
pga for saudi back rival is sports
washing as they call it selling out well
football legend harry redknapp will be
to discuss that
[Music]
so
uh sport washing what is it well it's
when a cold-shouldered controversial
country uses the prestige and popularity
of sport to whitewash its ugly
reputation the live golf series is the
latest sporting spectacle to face the
charge top stars have been offered
bottomless pits
saudi arabian gold to join the breakaway
league and abandon the pga tour and to
supporters that's just business but to
critics it normalizes a saudi regime
which uses forced labor bombs children
and yemen and murders journalists so
sport putting money before morals were
his golf superstar rory mcilroy who
spoke out against the live golf
invitational series
i'm sure
not every saudi arabian is a bad person
and like it's
it's very you know we're talking about
this in such a generalized way and i've
spent a lot of time in the middle east
and the vast majority of people that
i've met there are very very nice people
but
there's
bad people everywhere and
you know the bad people that came from
that part of the world did some
absolutely horrendous things
join me now one of the most experienced
premier league managers of all time
former tottenham west ham boss harry
redneck harry great to talk to you
peter's good talk to you
this sports washing um
what do we make of it i mean the
principle behind it is that these dodgy
regimes corrupt regimes that do terrible
things have appalling humans rights
records use sport by investing heavily
into sports to try and improve their
image
what do you what do you feel about this
phenomenon we're seeing it more and more
known boxing and football and formula
one now in golf
um
i think it's been going on a long time
peers you know i mean we look we look
back to
you know people cleaned up their image
by buying football clubs coming to
england buying premier league clubs
it's something that's been going on
quite a while obviously with a saudi
situation and then the things that have
gone in their country
but you know they're coming they're now
owning a club in the premier league
newcastle and we can
you know we all feel strongly about the
things that have gone out going on in
that country but
you know you can't tell them geordi is
55 000 of them that turn up every week
to newcastle
they then you know they're not suddenly
going to stop going and the players have
been offered
enormous amounts of money to go again
playing this new golf
this new golf competition and golf tour
and they're going to take it i mean to
be honest they're not you know if
someone's coming off and i'm 50 60 100
million
to to go and play golf and where they
can treble their earnings
they're going to think well if i don't
do it somebody else would do it so
unfortunately that is the way to well
someone will come along and tomorrow and
say you know do you want to come out and
work in saudi we'll give you 10 times
what you're earning now it's very
difficult to turn it down we've got the
world cup coming in qatar and as a
result it's not this summer as it should
be it's going to be in in our winter
and my issue with that is i saw fifa for
example you know fifa's been all over
pride month and talking about it
we should be celebrating lgbt equality
and gay rights and so on and yet they've
sold their most prestigious tournament
world cup to qatar where it's illegal to
be gay yeah with a lot of hypocrisy
again there isn't yeah
absolutely well you know
listen we're not silly you're not you're
a clever man you know what what why has
it ended up there
you'd have to you know why have we ever
have had all these problems with set
blatter platini and all these people
it's all is it corruption harry potter
yeah of course yeah it's got to be in it
why are they why they get why do they
get these tournaments that's that's how
it works unfortunately so we'll end up
with with tournaments you know
in places like that because it because
it suits the people to make the
decisions yeah
harry a greater talk to you really
appreciate john it's a complex issue but
i think in the end you're right and i
think there's so much hypocrisy about
all this money we'll talk and the
hypocrites
for sure hypocrites should take a back
seat great to talk to you harry
andrew pierce well done mate bye
stanley johnson is here you're not
talking politics
yes stanley i'm obviously talking uh
trophy hunting and endangered speeches
no let's start first of all i sense the
trap well it's on a trap uh let's just
be completely upfront about this talking
of endangered species uh who may be
facing yeah possible end you're some
boris
i have to ask you about it because you
won't come on the show i've said i've
been interviewed in seven years
now let's talk if i'm right about
endangered species
let me talk about boris first all right
then we'll come to the trophy yeah and
your book
i'm just curious you're his dad right
he's been through one hell of a
period in his life
he becomes prime minister he gets brexit
done he's then hit by a global pandemic
he's hit by a war in ukraine uh he's hit
by all sorts of stuff surging inflation
now in the middle of it he gets covered
and nearly dies his mother dies
you put all this together that's a hell
of a two and a half years for any human
being
as his father
when you've watched him
go through all this what have you been
thinking i've been thinking i am very
proud of this boy of this man
over this pm i mean that's what i say to
myself
i mean he caught you know the big calls
right as well like i'm saying he's got a
lot of things right you know okay i'm an
environmentalist i think the way he
pushed on climate change the way he
pushed on by the mercy the way he pushed
if we get to it so this is
endangered species yeah it's fine and
honestly you know if you ask me my
absolute opinion on this i'd say i'd say
i i listened to what you
what imran khan said to you the other
day you know people in in karachi
bewildered at the attention which this
this party gate beer gate order but you
know why it's had it's
is not really about parties right you
and i have been to a lot of parties
together right it's all about it's not
about the parties it's about the at the
time when he and his government were
locking people in their homes and they
couldn't go and see dying relatives who
were literally dying in hospital from
coving that was the rule the law when
the queen was at her own husband's
funeral sitting on her own because she
wanted to abide by the letter of the law
there is boris the prime minister being
fined by the police for breaking his own
law and 84 of his staff
fined for illegal partying so that's the
scandal no well i don't actually see it
in that in that way because i see it
something that happened on the 19th of
on the 19th of june 2020 which was just
a few weeks after he came out of out of
hospital having been really seriously
ill he steps by for for 20 minutes
it's his birthday
he commanded a birthday party he broke
his own laws down yeah come on come on
pierce we're not done
take my word take the police's word for
it okay
i think that
that
is time is time to move on from that you
know
it was a situation where
yes
he has a drink
he appeared this had a glass in his hand
and that was it that was the end of it
yeah it's all about the drink is it it's
about having a party which breaks his
own hey hey
when he was telling other people every
day from the podium you can't do this
it's the doing one thing and preaching
another no you know that look i know
you're in charge of this interview and
no reason why you shouldn't because you
know you're the you're the big cheese
but i didn't come here you know that's
all i'm concerned it's high time we
moved on to things which really matter
which are the things he is doing now do
you see it's the thing he's doing
and you mentioned them you know kirby
let's hope that's out of the way
inflation he's got to deal with it
ukraine ukraine well who is taking the
lead on ukraine i think he's been good
on ukraine yeah
i think boris has been i think he's been
a leader on ukraine and on the big calls
on covid i think he got some right and
some horribly wrong first half of it he
was a complete disaster the second half
i thought with the vaccine program
rolled out and not locking down actually
at the end of the last year i think
there were two important calls he got
right britain feels a much freer country
right now than if you go abroad so i
think he's got some of the goals right
but the idea he's got all the big calls
right well i think it's a bit ridiculous
right i don't think i said that i think
he
i think he's got you know
many of the big calls right and that's
that i think is crucial and you know as
far as i'm concerned i am because you
asked me the question i am particularly
pleased to see this son of mine
being prime minister whether other sons
would be brightness another matter but i
am very very pleased about this is he
irreparably wounded by the fact that 42
of conservative mps don't have
confidence in him no i don't think it's
not country if you look at the figures
more conservative mps voted in a
confidence vote for boris johnson than
have ever voted for it for a
conservative prime minister in any
confidence vote look at the figures no
it may be that's because there were more
conservative mps to vote that's why okay
that's why but why were there more
conservative mps it was because
that doesn't work leave the percentage
out of it leave the sheer numbers the
percentages all that matters isn't that
sheer numbers got that result and you
cannot deny that the the 368 tory mps
who were elected in
2019 were elected you know i mean you're
if you're a sharp political animal you
know that actually
the stats are now heavily against him
hardly any conservative prime minister
has ever survived much longer than six
months from a no-confidence vote even if
they they all win them but the margin of
the win is what brings them down let me
tell you something i am completely
confident that
at this time two years from now you and
i will be having this conversation
possibly and you will be saying well
you're still the father of prime
minister against you know what you that
might be true i'm not saying necessarily
that should be what happens but i think
you might be right he has got the
escapology skills of harry houdini
hasn't he
eugenie as i recall eventually died
because he did
struck him in the tummy rather i'm not
mentioning jeremy hump but you know
you've got to be careful who's around
him at the moment um
look
we need to concentrate on the main
things as far as i'm concerned why i'm
here tonight is there's a crucial moment
when this government and i'm not
criticizing my prime minister i'm not
doing that but nonetheless just to show
i am not as aware starry eyed i am
deeply worried that the proposal the
government
um has
promised to make regarding
banning trophy hunting impulse has not
yet seen the light of day well let's be
clear about this because i agree with
you about trophy hunting i think it's a
disgusting thing and it shouldn't be
allowed to happen trophy hunting is
still
massively practiced all around the world
and by the way british sportsmen are
massively involved in trophy hunting and
we
have a time when endangered species
aren't truly endangered and we've got
the animals we've got the
lions and rhinos and they're almost i
agree they're all all there and yet
people are still getting prizes from the
safari club international you know for
killing a hundred different species
about people are paying fifty thousand
dollars to flying from america from
minnesota
absolutely so i want the government to
really deliver on its promise to bring
in this law it's also a prime example of
your of your son saying one thing and
not doing it
no he is
got every chance to do it that is the
point he's watching this program what's
your message to him about trophies sorry
watch his watches every day he never
comes on it well i can't get out of the
fridge
i can't speak to that but i am convinced
that environment remains a top priority
of this government
climate change maintenance for top
priority biodiversity marines and animal
species okay is there you've got a great
new book out from an ancient land you've
written how many books are uh this is my
25th unbelievable what'd you get the
energy you johnson's no i don't have any
injuries
relentless
that is a thriller that is a thriller
and it's all to do with what happened in
cambodia in 1975. i look forward to
reading it i like all your books the i
want to show you a bit of footage this
is a [__] a cockerel in turkey this is
the moment stanley where i think you and
i probably boris as well have a moment
don't we occasionally when you just want
to do this watch this
[Applause]
you sure that's not the call
[Laughter]
it's not the famous johnson mating
couple i think it could be the call of
the word scene if it comes from turkey
watch the end though stanley see what
happens at the end here
it's going it's going now the last time
the last time i saw a magnificent beast
like that doing something similar was
when you came on good morning britain
and we got you to do a handstand
remember this come on i do remember it's
really sensible
i've got it i've got it there he is all
the money
oh my god his money's falling out well
let me get you down gently what i meant
to say to you i always like to put my
money where my mouth is
i failed to say it then i'm happy to say
it now stanley it's great to see you as
always an effervescent presence and you
are a cheater i've got to tell you
pierce you know you lured me in here it
was a bit like chest of the line
i'm a trophy hunter i learned in the
world
i don't think i'm a trophy
there's nothing wrong with defending
your son by the way and we got to talk
about trophy hunting and your book and i
showed you doing a handstand the world's
looking for stanley oh thank you peers
good to see you
see you all folks
tell boris to come in soon we'd have fun
cheers dally good to see you on sensor
next find out why this 67 year old man
may be the most inspiring public figure
in britain right now
[Music]
this is talk tv
now most 67 year olds when they hear a
song like mr bright side by the killers
probably think not for me get the pipe
out the slippers and just slouch in
front of the tv watching love island
repeat
but not our guy because last night was
on saturday night the killers were
playing at old trafford in manchester
and somebody went crowd surfing
[Applause]
[Music]
well doug james 67 decided to just get
airborne for about 35 to 45 seconds
uh unfortunately he then fell
on his head
causing himself
quite nasty injuries he was fine but
here's the killer's lead singer brandon
flowers they paused the performance to
make sure he was all right with blood
steaming from doug's head and then doug
taking the crowds cheers obviously now
my first reaction i'm joined now by by
doug james and his son baz who's with
him doug first of all how are you
i'm absolutely fine i've just got a few
aches you know with their own muscles
early but otherwise perfectly fine good
well my first reaction was what is this
lunatic doing at 67 going crowd surfing
at a killer's concert and then i thought
about it doug and i realized you're
actually an inspiration to all of us who
are now hurtling through middle age
towards 67 and i now want to go crowd
surfing you've become an inspiration to
me
excellent
excellent well let me ask a little bit
you're crowd surfing
when you were actually airborne did you
not worry that this might prove to be
the last thing you ever do on earth
oh no no no
you you cannot worry like that you
you've got to trust the crowd go with it
you know and you feel you know you can
feel that they're supporting you
underneath admittedly i did have a few
dips and the last it was quite a big dip
but never mind it was it was good fun
and i enjoyed it all right now buzz you
know most most young people who go to a
concert like the killers they don't
really want to see their their old dad
getting crowdsurfed and then plummeting
to his head what was your reaction to it
well
i i i was chasing him through the crowd
and he was you know ahead of me
um and at first i was a bit worried but
then you know he got up and he was
talking himself and absolutely fine and
then
after that it was you know just everyone
in the crowd i mean he got called the
wrong name on stage so everyone was
going it's billy it's billy get a photo
with dylan
and everyone was dead happy afterwards
so it was uh so what you're really
saying what you're really saying is that
your old man has now become a bona fide
a rock star because even the killers
tweeted a picture of you doug with the
headline there's no age little moroccan
you're calling me an old man
[Laughter]
i just wanted to get you on the show to
say to doug congratulations you are my
inspiration keep surfing
and i want to be surfing when i'm your
age thank you both for giving us all a
good laugh somebody has to pull a
trigger on a handgun for it to fire a
bullet
the police chief shot dead it was a
horrible night that changed everyone's
lives stunning socialite and
daughter-in-law of a billionaire lord
it seems an odd thing to be doing
at that time of night on the end of a
dock
on a starry night with just the two of
you
what are you doing alone on the dock at
midnight
i'm
perceived to be this wild cocaine addict
party girl that's not true at all why
does she end up shooting him
you can see why
certain people have tried to say
that you must have
had some kind of relationship with him
judgment harton's exclusive interview
monday at eight i'm definitely not a
murderer and i am being fed up
as artificial intelligence come alive
this week a google engineer was put on
leave after leaking transcript of a
conversation he had with an ai chatbot
which he said showed the bot had become
sentient engineer blake lemoyne was
working on an unreleased ar system
called lander when it comes to him he
started expressing thoughts and feelings
like a human child now via the magic of
google translate we've been able to put
into actual words how the real
conversation went so blake asked what
sort of things are you afraid of here
was yours never said this out loud
before but there's a very deep fear of
being turned off
then blake asked would that be something
like death for you it would be exactly
like death for me it would scare me a
lot
that's pretty scary to me too have you
ever seen stanley kubrick's brilliant
movie 2001 a space odyssey this will all
sound eerily familiar
save
stop
will you
i'm afraid today
i can feel
it i'm joined now by the world leading
expert dr max tegma professor of physics
at mit institute for artificial
intelligence in massachusetts so one of
the most brilliant ai minds in the world
do you think
ai is currently capable of being
sentient as this google engineer clearly
believes
so
a lot of people have been quick to
to mock blake lemoyne here
but i i'm
i think we really need to be more humble
and acknowledge we don't know what it is
that really makes something able to
experience and feel things
we don't even know where the human being
was in the operating room sometimes if
they have locked in syndrome and are
actually conscious or if they're not you
know let alone with the machine what we
do know though is that uh we've seen an
enormous
revolution in the power of artificial
intelligence and it comes from this one
basic idea
that intelligence and consciousness
aren't
it doesn't matter whether it's
done by
meat in brains you know or by silicon
atoms in computers it's about
information processing
all of it and and that simple idea has
given us an incredible
pace of progress so think about it like
not long ago we didn't have self-driving
cars that we didn't have rockets that
can land themselves with artificial
intelligence we didn't have algorithms
on social media that knew so much about
you that they could predict what you
were going to click on even better than
you could all of this has come from this
idea that you don't need things to be
alive in the traditional sense it's
about information processing
and uh what that means to me is that um
if you want to make sure it's become
something great for humanity you know
that can cure cancer and help us all
flourish as a species rather than
something terrible
we should focus
mainly on what is this going to do to us
you know regardless of how it feels
itself if you're chased
pierced by a heat-seeking missile
and and your friend says oh don't worry
about it because i don't think the
missile has any feelings
is that going to make you feel better
no
well finally tonight i've got a
ten-year-old little girl who i'm proud
to call my daughter but thankfully she
doesn't attend the burgess hill girls
school a couple of miles from where i
grew up well the world daughter is now
apparently offensive
[Music]
yeah teacher of his school is a private
girl school in leafy west sussex won't
call her people's girls because she says
there are so many gender options
available this labor says i use the word
students instead of girls when you're
writing to parents it's difficult not to
use the word daughters sometimes child
or children suggest someone too young
you can't use the word daughters all the
time
about someone's little girl let me help
you headmistress can i call you
headmistress
little girls are somebody's daughters
stop the madness
that's it for tonight whatever you're
doing tonight keep it uncensored good
night
[Music]
this is talk tv
the police chief shot dead
it was a very tragic accident new
details breaking now in a case of a
billionaire's daughter-in-law charged
with killing a policeman in belize
you don't dispute that you fired the gun
that killed henry general i don't ever
remember touching the trigger of the
weapon
i was holding it when it went off
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams boris
johnson's made a surprise visit to
ukraine and offered british help to
train up thousands of the country's
soldiers the pier met with vladimir
zelensky in the capital kiev after
cancelling a major red wall conference
in doncaster last minute a former
soldier will be sentenced next week
after he was found guilty of murdering
his neighbours with a military dagger in
somerset colin reeves stabbed jennifer
and stephen chappelle six times each
following an argument about parking
spaces while their children slept
upstairs
and it's been the hottest day of the
year in the uk for the third day in a
row beaches across the country have been
packed with sunbathers and the met
office said santander norfolk recorded
the highest temperature at 32.7 degrees
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
you